[Musique]
la différence d'âge entre hommes et
femmes a toujours été un sujet tabou
serait temps d'évoluer un peu autant en
moyenne les hommes ont deux ans et demi
de plus que leurs conjointes et ils sont
8% à avoir plus de dix ans d'écart en
france ce week-end ce sont des
internautes féministes qui s'en sont
pris à ce que certains appellent sugar
daddy et plus précisément à deux acteurs
français on année cinéma ça va vous
n'êtes pas si éloigné parce qu'une à des
cinémas ça vous disant vous avez quoi
trois ans d'écart séparent sans cassel
en couple avec tina cunac est mannequin
de 30 ans de moins de pluie jusqu'à quel
âge je continue à faire ce genre de
trucs et récemment romain duris en
couple avec l'actrice emma macquet et
avec qui il a plus de vingt ans d'écart
n'a créé une vraie complicité entre les
différents otages qui dérange pourtant
sur les réseaux de nombreuses personnes
ont apporté leur soutien aux deux stars
en défendant l'idée que l'amour n'a pas
d'âge c'est quoi ces polémiques sur
duris et cassel hall pays des libertés
une femme et un homme ne pourrait plus
aimé à cause de leur différence d'âge
d'un gain alors comprenez vous que
vincent cassel et romain duris soit
lynché pour sortir avec des femmes bien
plus jeune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est avec nous merci lola comprenez vous
de vincent cassel et romain duris soit
lynché pas sortie avec des femmes bien
plus jeune alors il y en ad oui il ya
des noms lola déjà merci d'être là mais
merci à vous ça va vous avez sept
enfants savaient très bien jean marie va
bien il a très bien bon très bien beau
lui fait un bisou de notre pas combien
d'années vous sépare 28 ans 28 ans des
cas dans lesquels vous êtes ensemble ça
fait 1
saison ces gens pourraient être
rencontrés à quel âge en fait lui
l'avait que c'était en primaire
merci jean marie l'adea ces problèmes
comme ça
non mais c'est vrai
ces rencontres et j'avais 24 ans
d'accord et lui donc il vit l'un avait
52 puisque je suis un petit peu calculé
voilà donc 24 ans 52 ans et c'est vrai
que ça tient de saison ouais vous avez
même eu des enfants sont là deux ans ans
exactement j'ai eu les bel avenir bravo
et merci
c'est vrai et est ce que vous avez senti
des gens qui vous regardent et avec
dédain qui disais c'est pas possible
c'est trop de différence d'âge je sais
c'est n'importe quoi ou pas du tout oui
bien sûr de toute façon les les
différents stages en fait elles ont
toujours
dérangé les gens je pense parce que
ça fascine autant que ça dérange moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est à dire que
comme on n'est pas dans la norme sociale
on est pointé du doigt parce que quelque
part on désobéit à un certain modèle
qu'on nous vend depuis depuis toujours
donc des comptes désobéit bas on est
pointé du doigt donc évidemment quand
j'avais 24 ans et lui 52 ce n'était pas
forcément très bien interprété mais de
la même manière que maintenant alors que
on a deux enfants que j'ai quand même 38
ans donc je suis pas une gamine
effectivement va lui ils vieillissent
normale et d'un risque forcément il dit
voilà forcément il a toujours ses 28 ans
d'écart avec moi mais il ya toujours
il ya toujours ce voile à ce malaise
dans votre famille dans votre famille
c'était accueilli comment alors dans ma
famille c'est ça aussi alors ce qui est
incroyable c'est que ma maman quand j'ai
rencontré jean marie elle a rencontré
son compagnon avec qui elle est toujours
l à 112 ans d'écart
ils ont 24 ans d'écart savoir que lui il
est plus jeune qu'elle donne en quatre
ans donc on a tout fait à l'envers maman
nous a fait penser à switcher
ouais on va peut-être faire sa jambe
maison mère et jean-marie finiront alors
et donc la voie est donc à elle est là
elle avec un garçon plus jeune veuve et
oui ils sont fous amoureux il n'obtient
aucun problème hier un conditionnel donc
en fait dans ma famille du côté de maman
ça a été très bien accueilli mon père un
petit peu moins parce que mon père il
m'a eu à 18 ans ouais donc forcément il
est plus jeune que jean marie a oui
c'est vrai donc c'est assez
spectaculaire choqué le calcul il a 56
ans et à 10 ans - ouais vous êtes bon
matin moi ça va non bien sûr il j'essaye
et du coup lui au début voilà mon père
il est très correct pour un papa très
carrée et tout au début il m'a dit tu
vas pas me faire ça quoi et jésus belge
lem mais ils étaient horrifiés
maintenant ils s'apprécient beaucoup
donc chez face à l'amour on est un je
pense obligé d'abdiquer critiques qui
vous ont blessés parfois ou pas du tout
où des mots des potes des amis de vos
amis dit elle disait quoi parce que
c'est vrai qu'on dira ses copines voilà
je suis avec un quand vous avez comme
vous êtes vous aviez donc 24 24 ans
votre copine à vous au moyen âge étant
au cours florent et où j'avais ma vie
d'étudiante quoi et c'est vrai que j'ai
des copines qui me disait mémé tu fais
quoi mais en fait ça m'a jamais blessé
ça m'a fait rigoler parce que moi de
toute façon je suis assez sûr de mes
choix de ce que je regrette jamais vous
avez jamais regretté
c'est donc vous avez fait le bon choix
oui bien entendu mais c'est vrai qu'il
peut y avoir des réflexions
désobligeantes même encore maintenant
alors que moi je trouve que la
différence d'âge se voit peut-être moins
parce que moi aussi je prends de l'âge
et et voilà et pourtant pour les gens
bien il voit la différence d'âge encore
maintenant à mon mari en rigolant indie
méthode sur la jeune fille et moi
j'évite péri dont la une du gentil mais
on a été gentils mais du coup moi je
vois là je j'ai appris à ne pas me
formaliser parce que je sais que
les gens sont sont dérangés des choses
qui les fascine et que je pense qu'il ya
une part de 2 non compréhension donc pas
forcément de jalousie mais il ya quelque
chose qui gêne quand on suit pas un
format qu'on nous vend depuis toujours
parce que les couples en général ils
seront contre voilà parfois même à la
fac tout ça donc nature on a dans
l'inconscient collectif qu'il faut avoir
le même âge et que ces voix là comme ça
tout ça crée de nombreuses jeunes filles
au master
finance annoncé à la fac à la minute
avec tout ça exactement comme à la fac à
la bibliothèque
vous vous êtes le seul à des dames et
oui avec emilio il faut construire au
proche- et déjà à vincent cassel et les
romains furent en fait il faut
comprendre la subtilité des gens qui
critiquent ces couples il ne juge pas
les signes twitter non mais il ne juge
pas les coûts selon m il juge le fait
que la publicité et le cinéma met en
avant des modèles de couple on a d'un
côté un homme qui est âgé riches et
puissants et de l'autre côté une femme
qui est jeune et jolie et je pense qu'il
ya plein de femmes qui en ont marre
d'être cantonné à l'or physique est à
l'orage parce que les femmes de 40 ans
de 50 ans de 60 ans on les voit ou au
cinéma on les voit ou à la télévision
nulle part donc je pense que c'est un
peu plus subtil que il faut pas de juger
des couples moi je suis pas du tout
votre coup c'est pas le problème c'est
plus le modèle que ça renvoie dans le
cas de vincent cassel et romain duris de
l'homme puissant riche et âgées et de la
femme jeune et jolie et qui n'est que je
n'ai je prends l exemple qu il a soulagé
que vincent cassel que ma mère aussi
ce qui est plus âgée que la femme est
encore un autre des barthes ensuite
c'est la femme qui est plus âgée que je
suis en euro s'ouvre à brigitte maxi
vous inquiétez pas ça tu es avec moi
alors vous vous êtes vous êtes choqués
donc bah je comprends en tout cas les
accords au gaz un de ceux qui me
critiquent alors je veux bien croire que
c'est sur c'est normal pour répondre
sinon vous allez vous y
compris mais il n'a pas se saborder
lui-même non mais c'est sûr a fait du
vélo gâté bas il va pas les trous et son
pneumatique c'est normal mais mes
ennemis dans le sillage des mouvements
féministes qui critiquent sexta alors
qu'en fait c'est elles font preuve d'un
sexisme incroyable parce qu'en fait on
critique en ce genre de couple ça veut
dire que la fab et s'est réduite à
l'état de conquête pour l'homme et à
l'état de femme vénale qui s'intéresse à
un homme plus âgé pas s'il a de l'argent
parce qu'il a réussi extra alors que
l'amour c'est pas ça c'est une rencontre
etc c'est pas ne s'épanouit qu'est ce
qui vous a séduit chez jean-marie me
bats avec jean-marie on a eu un coup de
foudre intellectuelle ans une bizarre
quand il puisse paraître et ça c'est un
truc pareil drame avec moi
je suis allé le voir sur scène c'est une
copine qui m'a dit allez viens on va
voir bigard j'ai deux places et tous
puis à bombay attendu gars je
connaissais qu'à moitié franchement je
l'avais vaguement entendu quand j'étais
petite à la télé quoi et du coup je suis
tombé sur sur le spectacle mon psy va
mieux et je les trouvais brille en fait
je les trouvais extrêmement drôle je
vais arriver que voilà foudre j'ai déjà
fait bon qu'il avait dragué non quand
même pas
en fait après on est allé dans sa loge
ouais et lui il est en arrêt sur image
quoi ouais j'ai un moment j'ai dit que
ce statut je me souviens encore et il
m'a dit non mais donc je disais belge
fait les cours florent et où il était
franchement il était en arrêt sur image
et moi au début je me suis dit bon ben
vous peut-être pas quand même et vous
invitent devant développement et
l'évolution vous avez de demander votre
main pas si vite que ça ouais pas si
vite que ça mais à l'issue d'une
première dispute on s'est séparés
pendant trois mois il l'a fait parce que
je le dis si tu reviens tu reviens
vraiment où tu reviens pas du tout en
fait s'il a son caractère ah ben il a
son petit caractère
mais c'est vrai que ce sont franchement
c'est son esprit qui m'a pas plu j'étais
mort de rire de tout spectacle je me
suis dit c'est un génie les esprits un
truc qui nous arrive à garder sa cage la
vienne oui vous franchement de guillaume
genton tête au fath et flippant oui
parce que sous couvert de progressisme
en fait j'aurais pas lié aux gens tant
celui qui embrasse les gens qui ont
vraiment bien ça on sait qu'aucun état
doit progressivement fait une sorte
d'ayatollahs féministe pas à ce qu'on
fait de la question c'est comprenez vous
que romain duris et vincent cassel soit
lancé pour sortir avec des femmes je
suis heureux pour eux mais doit on dit
pas comprenez vous que tina et emma soit
lent chez pour sortir avec des hommes
plus vieux parce qu'elles sont
amoureuses parce qu'elle les aime et
tous à terre que toi tu veux
déconstruire le coup sous-entendu dans
un courrier à forcément une victime ils
ont l'air très amoureux j'ai vu vincent
cassel et n'a franchement ils sont très
amoureux et la décision prise est en
fait lui une sorte de mal de plus de 50
en dominant qui est donc sous emprise et
en plus il se trouve que sina et noir
alors là c'est encore pire alors là
c'est le crime de lèse majesté ça veut
dire que lui en plus à une sorte de
culture dominante du blanc sur le noir
franchement c'est dégoûtant c'est pas le
couple en lui même c'est la
représentation qu'on en fait et de la le
disait très justement pourquoi on met
pas plus en avant des femmes plus âgées
qui sortent avec désormais 6 et
notamment aussi
nous arriver c'est qu'on le voit assis
sur le toit merci d'abord votre argument
et les rôles ici tes soucis techniques
des femmes agitant un message
demandant pas
démocratisé ça ils ont bousculé en a
plein qui ont des noms mais c'est vrai
mais quand même la figure présidentielle
là on ne peut pas faire mieux donc on ne
peut pas faire mieux mais donc du coup
je pense que ça c'est quand même plus
rentrer dans les moeurs mais moi ce qui
me ce qui me chiffonne en fait c'est
quand vous chantez 1 on est encore avec
ce jour-là ce problème de mentalité face
et c'est ça rentre pas dans les
montagnes de chiffonner strech étonné
parce que pour moi en fait c'est de la
même manière qu'il ya encore des gens
qui ne cautionnent pas des couples voilà
avec des différences de religion des
différences de couleurs des différences
d'âgés pour moi c'est la même chose avec
les enfants ça se passe bien il ya un
racisme son cash flow enfants et rend
donc à l'âge aux enfants ils ont ils
vont avoir neuf ans malheureusement
d'accord mais c'est des jours oui je ne
comprends pas
non mais j'aime bien savoir peut jouer
11 novembre d'accord et ça se passe très
bien ils vous regardent vous aime
beaucoup vos jeux sur fait des gros
bisous à merci matin des bagues kelly v
de v line orale mais non excusez-moi de
vous avoir dérangé
je pensais j'ai écouté attentivement
parce que c'est bella et jules c'est ça
oui j'adore les prénoms mais là un petit
point mise à mort par les logiciels a
fait coup double à wignehies forcément
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce que la
chanter bel âge pour ça elle a fait le
type de verre alors pour le coup ça
avait vraiment aucun rapport
alors oui moi ya quelques années c'est
quelque chose que à des fins
personnelles jeu ça me enfin c'était pas
je
fais franchement je n'ai pas envie de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet là
[Rires]
mais elle a fait du vélo ce week-end la
cantine est alors à tête des templiers
tonné petit show très
haut potentiel ah ouais en tout cas l'on
vient de moi je vais faire si
nous livre
ses confidences ma belle-mère à la mon
âge là la femme de mon père de jean
pierre si vous dites ils ont 25 ans
d'écart quoi la savane on highway et ils
font ensemble depuis la rentrée c'est
vrai que mon père a au début quand il
est vrai que ma belle-mère baïla il a
assumé il ya pas mal de romane de
commentaires assez assez dur d'ailleurs
parfois donc je trouve ça très injuste
pour 20,5 à céder romain duris parce que
pour le coup c'est une chose que j'ai
vécue y compris dans ma famille parce
qu'elle a ma mère mon père elle même
était un peu voilà c'est ça ce n'est pas
quoi et emilie gasc à ses environs oui
en fait moi je pense surtout aux enfants
qu'ils ont eu de précédent mariage le
couple bien évidemment dans un monde
idéal il n'y a pas de problème d'âge on
s'en fout de sexe de couleur ou quoi que
ce soit dans un monde idéal tout le
monde s'en fout de tout c'est pas le cas
et en l'occurrence vincent cassel il a
des enfants qui sont des ados et jeunes
filles de 17 ans non plus voilà et quads
me catala débat quand il a débarqué avec
sanaa de 24 ans donc cette année car je
pense que l saduis faire quelque chose
aussi ça doit faire un peu bizarre et
donc c'est plus de ce côté là moi que je
me pose c'est déjà pas évident d'être
enfant de star je pense
ça brille c'est que tu penses à la
kalach la femme
de 28 ans et plus 1 victoire ah ouais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
l'accouchement et demi de plus pour
l'homme et merci
alors serait ce pas je me tais silva
mais la différence d'âge en fait c'est
marrant parce que moi je viens d'une
famille ou mes parents c'était déjà un
peu voilà il y avait une dizaine
d'années différence est en fait c'était
au fur et à mesure mon remontait il y
avait jusqu'à 25 26 ans d'écart est
d'accord apparemment c'était en italie
pour le coup du sud c'était très courant
une certaine époque c'était pas il ne
s'était pas une discussion en fait ce
n'est pas une question après moi ce que
je crois dans des situations comme ça
c'est marrant parce que j'ai découvert
que la sociologie s'y intéressait en
fait elle s'est bien sûr
et en fait il me semble qu'il fallait
faire très attention à moi je compte moi
qu'une fois pas contrairement lew
confirmant à guillon ne peut pas se
faire lyncher c'est à chaque écoute de
série et ça quelque chose d'assez lui la
sociologie est abordée alors il ya un
retour de kelly bedrani bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
et
six secondes dans les bars
oui bonsoir non moi ce que
parler d d d d d enfants potentiellement
de leur leur tristesse vis-à-vis de ce
couple ben moi ce que j'en pense c'est
que je pense que les enfants un moment
donné sont assez intelligents pour être
heureux de voir le bonheur de leurs
parents selon me voir un enfant qui voit
le bonheur de ses parents bientôt qu'un
enfant qui voit que les parents se
déchirent ou qui se force justement
rentrer dans les codes pour faire
plaisir aux hawks in alba voilà ce que
disaient les quais d'une haïti parce que
les enfants c'est pas des vinyles et il
voit quand quand leur enfant on écrit
sur les murs tamales encre de nos rêves
non mais c'est vrai on écrit sur les
murs à l'encontre de noël nous écrire
forme de graffitis les kids united merci
fermez vos gueules merci